SHILPA: It is my
extreme pleasure
to introduce to you
all Harold Davis,
an award-winning
photographer, the author
of several bestselling books
about photography and image
processing.
And his artwork, we have
some in the back of the room.
You're going to see
some on the slides.
It's been shown all
around the world.
So we're really
excited for Harold
to be here with us to share
the passion and the story
behind the photos.
And with that, please welcome
me in joining Harold Davis.
[APPLAUSE]
HAROLD DAVIS: Hi, everybody.
Thank you very much
for having me here.
It's really fun to be
at Google, the thing
I use every day, all the
time, for everything.
So hi, everyone.
I'm a photographer and a writer.
And when I was asked to think
about this talk, what Shilpa
said to me is tips and
techniques to help people
become a better
photographer is what
is going to matter to them.
I started to think
about this, and I
don't know how to put
this very politely,
but the fact is that for
technically competent people--
which I'm going to
make the assumption
that everyone in this room is--
the technical part of
pragmatic photography
can be encapsulated in somewhere
between six and 12 slides.
So that's not the hard part.
The hard part is the
non-technical part.
It's a non-hierarchical
field that, once you master
the gear and the
theory of exposure,
it's more about
feeling, spirituality,
things that are a bit
more touchy-feely.
So I decided to call my talk
"The Zen of Photography."
And here's a message from
your sponsor, my book that's
for sale out there.
This is a new
hot-off-the-press book.
It's called "The Photographer's
Black and White Handbook."
I'm the author of 19
photography books, some of which
have been bestsellers.
I'm also the author of
about 30 other books
on a variety of topics.
This was my previous
photography book,
which was called "Achieving Your
Potential as a Photographer."
And the one before that,
"The Way of the Digital
Photographer."
And here are some of
my backlist titles
on Photoshop, on black and white
photography, night photography,
macro photography.
I've been translated
into about 20 languages.
This is the Spanish
edition of one
of my black and white books.
Lest you think I only know
about photography, if you look
carefully at these
slides, you'll
note that my name is on these
books related to Google,
including the still-in-print
"Google Advertising
Tools" in its second edition.
So I've had a number of lives.
And I'm going to
say that there's
more to life than a cubicle.
That said, if I can convey
the sense in this talk
that what every field
that's worth doing
is about a soaring
imagination, that
would be what I want to convey.
You can have a soaring
imagination in a cubicle,
in fact.
But I have lived a life,
since I left programming
and IT behind, that has
been very adventurous
and taken me to some
incredibly wild places.
This talk is organized into
a section on black and white
and then a somewhat
mirroring section on color.
So let's start with this
image of a workbench.
It's an antique
Russian workbench
in Fort Ross, where the Russians
back in the 19th century
owned about half of
what's now California.
And note that I
created this photograph
to look as much like
an etching as a photo.
So I am a post-film
digital photographer.
One of my collectors said,
Harold, what you really do
is you use photographs
as your source material,
digital photographs as
your source material,
and you paint with them.
And that's a fairly
accurate depiction.
What I do is one
part digital painting
and one part photography.
It's important to realize that
essentially what a camera is
these days is a computer
with a lens at one end
and a scanner at the other end.
I call this image "The
Road Less Traveled."
And basically, it's a
foggy day near where
I live at the Green Dragons
[INAUDIBLE] Monastery.
And there are two roads,
and you can make a choice--
take the easy one,
or take the hard one,
or try to live up fully
to your potential.
What is it that you can do
that's most worth doing?
One thing that photographers
at a certain point run into
is many images have
been made already.
Ansel Adams made,
essentially, a great image
from the spot, Tunnel
View, in Yosemite Valley.
And you go there, and when
the light is pretty good,
you see about 50
photographers lined up
with tripods making the image,
but it's still worth doing.
I use this image of a
slot canyon in Arizona
to show that, even
though you have
tons of information
in photography,
it's not always wise to show it.
The photographs you've
seen are largely
what are called monochromatic
HDR photographs, namely,
they're bracketed
sequences of shots.
But with this image,
the black area
at the bottom, the
triangle, and up at the top,
I had plenty of
information to reproduce
every detail in
there, but I chose
not to to make a dramatic
ribbon of light at the top.
So the topic of
light is something
that comes up a great deal in
photography for good reasons.
Not only is it built into
the word "photography,"
"writing with light," but
as a matter of physics,
it's absolutely impossible
to photograph an object.
All you can capture
using a sensor
is light that is
emitted or reflected
by an object, one or the other.
So one of the really
important things
as you start to take your photos
beyond the just common level
is to analyze the
light that's coming in.
Is it reflected?
Is it emitted?
What is it reflected
or emitted by?
That will get you pretty far
in terms of understanding it.
This is a nice
reflection in a pond
up in Maine at Maine Media
Workshops, where I teach.
So many black and
white images are best
done where there is essentially
an absence of visual color
anyhow.
One of the ways you
say, hey, is something
going to work for black and
white, is to look out and say,
there's not much
color here anyhow.
And at night is a good
time to find that.
During the day, this
would essentially
have been impossible to make
in black and white or color
because it would
be full of people.
But at night,
there's nobody there,
and you can get a nice
range, dynamic range,
from darkest dark
to blackest white.
An overlooked but
very difficult part
of being a professional or
serious amateur photographer
today is data management.
I have upwards of 100
terabytes of data.
I have to be able to find stuff.
When I have a client
who wants to license
an image from 10
years ago, I need
to be able to find
the relevant files.
So one of the things I help
educate photographers in
is how to maintain
a content management
system for photography.
So there are many ways you can
get black and white images.
You can set your camera to do a
black and white JPEG, and then
the next image, you
turn it off, so you
can have black and white color.
But the recommendation for high
quality black and white that
can be reproduced like
the prints of mine you see
in the back, or in
really high quality,
or like the book
that is back there,
is to create a four-color
image, and then,
using one or more RAW files--
and the loop towards your right
on this particular diagram
is the question of whether
it's one or more files--
convert it to color, and
then use a layered conversion
to black and white.
So this is a little
bit like the old zone
system was for
chemical photography,
because using targeted layers,
layer masks, and painting
tools, you can say
exactly how you
want to convert each part of
an image to black and white.
And it doesn't all
have to be the same.
And that's a really
important point.
Essentially, there's a hierarchy
of black and white conversion
techniques where one axis
here is the effort involved,
and the other is the quality.
This could be summed
up "no pain, no gain."
So I spent a lot of time
in the Photoshop darkroom.
Generally, for any kind of
photography, what really
happens is you get some kind of
concept, and then you go out,
and you try and photograph it.
And there's a recognition
of whether you got it.
And then you go back, and
you say, how did it work?
Or maybe it didn't work so well.
Let me plan to do it again.
And then you go,
and you process it.
And ultimately, at the bottom
of this hierarchy of things
you do, you edit.
And edit is a hugely important
process in photography.
And then you show it, you
print it, you put it in a book.
I don't feel I really
understand any of my images
until they're
beyond the monitors.
You can't really tell
for sure how good
an image is as
long as it is only
seen digitally on monitors.
So I worry most about
whether my images
convey a quality of emotion.
That's what I care about.
And you can take a fairly
commonly photographed object,
like this nautilus shell.
Somewhat counterintuitively,
I photographed
this nautilus shell on a
white light background.
There was light
coming through it.
And then I transformed it into
a black background in Photoshop.
And it's been a standout image,
reproduced many, many times
all over the place.
And people don't
really understand
that part of the reason
for that is the glow that's
coming through the
shell, which you wouldn't
see if you lit it differently.
Of course, you can
also go and see
whether you can shoot vegetables
to look like women or waves
coming in on the ocean.
And one of the really fun
things about photography
is the way you can control
how motion is rendered,
such as the motion of
water in these waves.
It's the shutter
speed setting, which
is very badly named, because
it's not actually a speed,
it's a duration of time.
So that's a good takeaway
for the six technical slides.
Shutter speed is not a speed.
It is a duration of time.
And how motion is
going to be rendered
depends upon how much time
you expose the subject
to the medium in your camera.
A tell with this
photo that it's not
exactly what it seems
in terms of the lighting
is the fact that the
freighter in the background
has lights on.
So this was captured
at about midnight
on a dark, cloudy night.
The long exposure makes for
the luminosity, and the clouds,
and the water.
And again, this is really
a question of the light.
From a digital
camera's point of view,
if you vary the exposure to
vary for the quantity of light,
it doesn't really care whether
it's low light or high light
very much.
There are a couple
of footnotes on that,
but that's basically true.
And again, another long exposure
water image, the Cayucos
Pier off the coast
of California.
One of the things I look for
in my black and white images
is what's called high-key
and low-key imagery.
This is a bridge near Astoria,
Oregon, over a big bay.
And my purpose in doing it was
to go from dark on the left
to light on the right.
And this is the opposite--
a dark image at night
where the purpose is to
create a dark look about it.
And the sun's setting behind
Bixby Bridge on the Big Sur
coast, which, by the
way, as you may know,
is now closed to all traffic
because of 45 mudslides
all along the
coast or something.
With this night shot of the Bay
Bridge in San Francisco, what
I did was I timed it so
that the moon was behind
the pillar of the bridge there.
A joke is that it used to be
hard to do things like this.
And these days, there are
a couple of different apps
that let you calculate
sun, moon, position, angle.
One is called The
Photographer's Ephemeris, TPE,
and it's basically
a Google Maps mashup
that's got the right sun
and moon charts in it.
Safety pin is an
object in California.
It says, if you're an
immigrant, you're OK with us.
We're not going to turn you in.
So I don't know whether that's
a symbol here yet or not,
but it is for us.
So one of the things
that used to be,
when I was a film photographer
in the darkroom, I
used to use chemicals
to create toning.
There was a process
called solarization,
where you would turn the
light on in the darkroom
and partly expose the
paper as it was processing.
Well, there are
various simulated ways
to do the same technique with
black and white photography
in the digital darkroom.
Also, you can use things like
mobile phones and mobile phone
apps.
So the last two photographs that
I've shown you are iPhone apps.
This is an iPhone app also.
And what I have
found recently is
that there is actually a market
for reasonable size prints
that I make on the iPhone.
And one of these days,
I'm going to just
give up the big cameras and
the 30-pound gear on my back
and just carry my iPhone around.
Maybe.
As if.
People look at this image.
Is it Chinese mountains?
No.
It's a beach with sand, and
you can see the footprints
at the top.
So seeing is what
photography is really about.
With this one, I timed
it so that the moon
was rising in increments
enough that it bisected
the previous shot of the moon.
The cables you see there
are the Golden Gate Bridge.
And one neat trick you
can do in black and white
is you can invert images.
Like in the chemical
darkroom, the difference
between positive and negative,
a negative was the negative,
and a print was the positive.
Well, these days, you
can do the same thing
and flip back and forth easily.
So if you want to create an
image like this Tuscan road
in an antique frame, it's
really pretty easy to do that.
This image of the
rooftops of Paris
is what's called split-toned
in black and white.
Sorry about that.
I processed part of it for
the roofs for one tonality
and the buildings for another
to create greater gradations
in the size of the building.
Point here, really, in
this sepia-toned image
is that the circumflex
is like a little face
alone on the keyboard.
And another sepia image.
So some of my images are what's
called monochromatic HDR, which
means they're extra high
resolution black and white
done through a sequence of
captures that are combined.
And things like this
one where, if you
think about where
the sun is coming up
under this dragon in
the Anza-Borrego Desert,
this side of the dragon
would be totally black.
But it's blended
together so that I
have the white and the black.
And the last was the wheels
that run the San Francisco cable
cars.
And this is a slot
canyon in Arizona.
And as you can see, my
photography in recent years
has taken me all over the world.
And it's also taken me
to places like this,
which is under the
Berkeley, California, pier,
and I got to share it
with rats and crabs.
So being a photographer
professionally is not
for the squeamish, necessarily.
It is for people who enjoy
seeing beautiful things.
This is along the Kumano
Kodo pilgrimage trail
in Japan in the Kii Mountains.
And it's called The
View of 10,000 Peaks
from a particular pass.
There are about maybe
100 I could count,
but they say 10,000.
Now if you just noticed, there
is a black and white version,
and here is a color
version of the same.
Here is a color
version of the shot
of the Pyramid in the Louvre
Court that I showed you
a couple of slides ago as well.
So my pattern here is
that I'm mirroring back,
and I've moved into color.
But the point,
really, is you don't
have to decide whether you're
doing black and white or color
until you come to
process the image.
You shoot everything the same,
really, as an RGB color RAW
file.
So digital photography
is a reality.
No, it's not reality, it's art.
If I were a
journalist, there would
be a strict code about
what I had to do,
and I would hope I
would adhere to it.
But as a photographic artist,
I can do whatever I want
and wherever my
imagination takes me.
I like to photograph
glasses at the dinner table
when I'm traveling since
I do so much traveling.
And this, I think of as the
Eye of Sauron in a wine glass.
And this one was
more intentional
because what I did was I put
a marble on a piece of paper,
lit it with a
single strong light,
and then I blended a shot of
the ocean into the shadow.
So obviously,
something like this
is a photo composition with a
nautilus shell and a drawing
render of a photo,
so it's a drawing
coming to life, kind of.
And similarly with this, this is
an in-camera multiple exposure
done with choreography with
a single model and studio
strobes.
And this also, I had the
model basically pirouette
on a ring in the air and
photographed her about eight
times.
And similarly here, the effect
is one of an Indian goddess.
So a camera is an
extension of ourselves.
For me, it's a way to explore,
to get to know things,
to understand things,
to see the things I love
about this wonderful
Earth of ours,
to explore what
happens with time.
This is an
eight-minute exposure.
What happens to the roaring
waves of the Pacific
when they roar in
at eight minutes?
They smooth out and get calm.
This is Tuscany.
This is the Lombard
region of lakes in Italy
with the blue light of dawn.
The joke about photographers
who care about color
is that what you
really care about
is the blue light at dawn,
and then the golden hour
a half hour before
sunset, and the blue light
after that golden hour, and you
can sleep the rest of the day.
And this is more or less true.
It's a hill town in France
and a hill town in Italy.
So, yes, let's wonder
about what's out there.
That's a great goal
for photography.
This is the town and
monastery of Nachisan,
which is at the inland sea
terminus of the Kumano Kodo
trail in Japan.
And I tried to add
painting elements
to this image to make it
look a bit like Shangri-La.
A park in the suburbs of Paris.
People.
Proper study of
people as people.
This guy had four kids,
and he had them all
tattooed on himself.
I have four kids too, but I'm
not going to tattoo them on me.
This is my youngest, my
daughter, Katie Rose.
There she is.
There they are.
This is a model that I
photographed for a while
in Paris.
My third son.
Here he is again.
There am I. You got to
take things a little
lightly sometimes.
That's just to see
if you're awake.
Want to take better photos?
Well, the first thing
you say is stand in front
of more interesting things.
Yeah, if you go to
the Marin Headlands
in front of the
Golden Gate Bridge,
you'll take better
pictures, probably.
But the real trick is to have
something interesting to say.
Every photo is a
kind of narrative,
and it's a poem or a story.
And you can't do
a great narrative
without some idea
of who you are.
Now this one.
OK.
There's a nice list
there on the right,
but leaving that
outside, consider this
an example of multitasking.
By the way, so potty,
meal, mouse, and clicker.
My son hates it when
I show this slide.
I'm a digital painter, and I use
photos for my source material.
One of the interesting
things about photography
is that there are so
many different uses
you can make of it.
This image I call
"A Kiss for a Rose."
And it's interesting
from a Google perspective
because if you search Google
Images for "Georgia O'Keeffe,"
"rose," this is always
on the return list,
which, since she's a great
painter, I don't mind.
One of the things I really
love to photograph are flowers.
This is an arrangement that I
shot on a backlit light box.
Somebody said to me it looks
like Bulgarian folk art.
But I actually think of
it as a low geostationary
orbit of jasmine buds
around a clematis.
So it all depends how
you look at things.
And more light box
flower photography.
So one of the ways that it's
interesting to print some
of these images is to
take nice exotic papers
and make them look
like something special.
Like this image of the
Sagrada Familia in Barcelona
can look beautiful
on a metallic paper.
In my book "Achieving
Your Potential,"
there is a story of a hero's
journey at the end where people
can fill out their stops.
And in some ways, being an
artist or a photographer
is like going on a journey
and taking a quest.
And sometimes, if
you're open to things,
there are side
trips on the quest.
Beginner's mind is great.
I envy anybody in here who
doesn't know much about
photography because that
means you can experiment.
You can try anything you want.
And you don't have to
say, OK, each image
has to be really good.
You can just try it and see.
That's really how I learned.
I tried everything
I could think of.
And I'm going to
just finish it up
with a couple of night images.
The last one you saw
was at Jemaa el-Fnaa
in Marrakesh, the
place of the dead
where they have camels
and everything else
you can imagine.
This is about a two-hour
exposure off Point Reyes,
and look what happens
again to the giant rollers
from the Pacific when you
calm them out like that.
This is an about
three-hour exposure
in the great Bristlecone Pine
Forest of the White Mountains
of California, and these are the
world's oldest living things.
Imagine.
So these kinds of photos
of the night that I
take that are multiple-hour
exposures are like the world
as a tree or a rock sees them.
It's also worth noting that
as Vincent van Gogh said,
the colors of the night can
be as vibrant and charged
as the colors of the day.
I like answering emails
related to photography,
and here's some of my
contact info and my blog.
And with that,
thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SHILPA: Thank you,
Harold, for sharing
all those wonderful
pictures and insights.
So now, I get the
opportunity to ask
you some questions
about the inspiration
behind going into
photography and why
you started in this discipline.
So I read that you actually
went to computer science school
and had a math major as well,
and then went to law school.
And then what
changed the direction
of what you were focusing
to go into something
so much more creative?
HAROLD DAVIS: Well, they're
two separate questions.
Thank you.
Law school wasn't for me.
I'm just not cut
out to be a lawyer.
In terms of my background
as a computer programmer,
it's something I
still love, and I
think it's a very
creative endeavor,
and I think it has
a lot in common
with being a photographer
at its highest practice.
There's a very zen aspect
to good programming.
SHILPA: Thank you
for noting that,
because I think that's
important to showcase
that both elements are
creative in their own art form.
And how have you
leveraged that foundation
with what you do
today in processing?
HAROLD DAVIS: Well, that's
an interesting question.
At the core level, I'm
not scared of computers.
And I worked for an
enterprise database company.
I know how to create a CMS.
And I know how to
write Photoshop macros.
I've written probably a dozen
books on programming languages,
from C# to Java and so on.
And I've worked for major
software houses and so on.
And I joke, the only
thing I program these days
are Photoshop macros,
but it's so important.
After all, what you have
with a digital photo
are bits of information,
just like in a computer.
And you have to have
some sense of how you can
organize these and use them.
Now, true, I'm using a
high-level program in Photoshop
with visual feedback, but
still, having some concept
of the modeling that's
going on underneath
and what calculations it's
making is really crucial.
SHILPA: Thank you
for sharing that.
Did you find that translating
and molding that background
and applying it to photography
and to writing was difficult?
Did you find changing
that mindset--
HAROLD DAVIS: That's a
great question, Shilpa.
There are a couple
of aspects to it.
Writing a book, when it's
a technical how-to book,
at any rate, is an issue
of organization, largely.
If you have a good
outline, then each chapter
is writing a term
paper in college.
I don't know about you,
but I was pretty good
at term papers in college.
In fact, I partly worked
my way through college
with writing term
papers for other people.
SHILPA: Wow.
I needed you.
HAROLD DAVIS: A book,
if you're well-organized
and you break it down into
bit-sized pieces, that's what's
involved in writing a book.
You can't teach
something to somebody
unless you understand it.
And at the same time, teaching
it or writing a book about it
is a great way to learn it
more deeply because you really
have to know it to explain
it and write about it.
On the other hand, there
really is a different mindset
from working for a
technology company
and being a free,
creative person.
And sometimes, I almost have
to turn a switch for myself.
SHILPA: I know.
I find that even
personally, when
I try to do that,
it's a struggle
to switch between the two hats.
But you've done it so well and
integrated the two together so
beautifully, as we saw today.
So talking about the book, "The
Photographer's Black and White
Handbook," you alluded
to it, but let's
talk a little bit more about
why only black and white.
HAROLD DAVIS: Well,
one of the things
that works very well
with photography
is to intentionally
choose limits
because that gets
you some constraints
that you can bounce against.
So I like doing that
in a number of ways.
Sometimes, I'm
going to say, hey,
I'll go out and just photograph
with one lens today, one
focal length, or
maybe one aperture.
So black and white is
interesting that way.
But it's also
interesting because color
is very seductive.
When you see something
in color, it's
like you're going
to go to that first.
And it hides a
multiplicity of flaws.
Portraying something
in black and white
is like portraying its bones,
the essence of a thing.
Composition matters much more
in black and white photography
than it does in color.
There's also an
instinctive reaction
that people have when
you present something
in black and white because
they know it isn't natural.
It's not the world.
This business that
photography is
reality, which is never
true anyhow, that's
cut when you say black
and white because they
know it's not reality.
So it's a way of setting
it off and saying,
this is art that is
strong and powerful.
And that also has a little bit
to do with the historical roots
of photography because it was
black and white for so long,
up until the late 1950s, really.
SHILPA: And so there's a
varying level of photographers
in the audience
today, so if they
are interested in
capturing a really
beautiful black and white image,
is there a certain equipment
list, a certain tool to use in
post-production or post-imaging
that you would recommend?
HAROLD DAVIS: Well,
the best camera to use
is the one you have with you.
That sounds like a piece of
sophism, but it's very true.
So I would say the
first piece of advice
I would have is start carrying
a camera around with you.
Because what often happens
is we hit something,
and for some reason we don't
stop to take a photo of it.
Like on my way walking down
here, I passed a fire hydrant.
And the top of the hydrant had
this wonderful hexagonal, shiny
nut on top of it
behind a red thing.
So I stopped with my
iPhone, and took the time
to compose it right, and
did a symmetrical shot
of the fire hydrant.
So I'm not a gearhead.
That's one of the
things that comes up
a fair amount in my
workshops and stuff.
It's just not the
most important part.
That said, if you
want to do some
of the things I
do professionally,
which is to reproduce
a mural that's
10 feet by 20 feet with
nice resolution or something
like that, you do need
high-resolution gear,
good lenses, tripods,
good technique, and so on.
I do recommend
Photoshop as the tool
to use for processing
photos, but Lightroom,
Adobe's other offering,
is also pretty good.
SHILPA: OK, great.
And then in terms
of apps, you had
mentioned that
there are some apps
that you use on your iPhone.
For folks out there that
use Android as well,
what apps would you recommend
for image filtering or post?
HAROLD DAVIS: Here's a
message from our sponsor.
The go-to app on the
iPhone is Google Snapseed.
It beats anything else out
there by an order of magnitude.
SHILPA: I'm glad to hear that.
HAROLD DAVIS: Yeah.
So I actually have a list of
recommended apps that I use,
and I'd be happy to
send it to anyone who
wants it who sends me an email.
Besides that, I do like
some of the Painterly apps.
There's a thing called
Waterlogue that's really good.
There are a variety of things.
Oddly, you can actually
do layers and masking
on the iPhone.
There's an app
called Leonardo that
lets you do gradients,
layers, masking, and so on.
I find when I'm
doing that that I
must be totally insane and
obsessive-compulsive because
here I am painting a mask
on a stupid little screen,
but you can do it.
SHILPA: Thank you.
I already spent
an hour filtering
using Instagram
filters, so I can only
imagine opening up
to the world of apps,
I will spend five hours,
probably, filtering a picture.
So thank you for that.
And one thing that you
mentioned on one of the slides
was interesting.
You said that, in order to
really capture a great picture,
you need to become an
interesting person,
as a matter of fact.
So how did you, in your life--
or how do you define
what is interesting?
HAROLD DAVIS: Yes.
[LAUGH]
There's no single
answer to that.
But try to not be
a narrow person.
Try and be nice to
the people around you.
Try and read a
lot, go exploring,
go hiking, embrace trees.
SHILPA: So if there's somebody
out there that's like,
am I interesting?
Am I not sure?
Just be who you are and
then take it from there
to capture the moment.
HAROLD DAVIS: Be who
you are, but more so.
SHILPA: OK, well, that
should be easy enough.
HAROLD DAVIS: You think?
SHILPA: And so I did want to
give the chance to the audience
to ask a question.
So there's two mics
as well, so feel
free to jump up
and queue up if you
have any questions for Harold.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
question about ratios
of photos that you take to
the ones that are actually
worth showing and that you
would publish somewhere.
Is your technique you
would go out and, say, take
1,000 photos in a day?
Or are you looking for
very specific compositions,
and you know what you
want before you take it,
so you take a lot fewer?
And I'm also curious, it would
be very interesting to see
the ones that were dead on, that
were worth publishing, versus
the ones near the same subject,
but the composition isn't quite
right, and an analysis of what
was not quite right about that,
and how you fixed it
in a subsequent shot.
HAROLD DAVIS: That's
a great question.
The fact of life is
that, like everybody
who's a professional
photographer,
I shoot many things I
never want to show anyone.
And you probably would
have to put things
under my fingernails to get
me to show you the bad ones.
But nonetheless,
your point, really,
is very, very well taken.
And interestingly, I do lead
workshops, and what I find
is that I tend to photograph
less than the people
in my workshops.
I am somewhat
targeted in what I do,
and I do often have
an idea in advance
of what it's going to
be or why I'm doing it,
and I wait till I see something
really good to take the photo.
But that said, of a given
session where, let's say, just
off the top of my head,
I took 200 RAW files,
I might have one.
So another way to
look at this is
consider that if you
had a painter who
did one great painting a week.
That would be 52 great
paintings a year.
That would be 150 great
paintings in three years.
That would beat Picasso cold.
So somehow, photographers are
expected to do more than that,
and it's not realistic.
But it's in my interest
as a professional
not to show crappy work.
So I try to be
sensible about that.
The other thing is that you
can't judge it immediately
after taking it.
That's not possible because
you're not objective.
I couldn't take a picture
if I didn't think,
hey, there's something
here, I love it.
So I'm in love with my
photos when I take them.
When I look at them
back on a monitor--
and part of the trick
to this is to look
at them both big and small.
You want to see them at
100% on a huge monitor.
You also want to see what
they look like as a thumbnail.
And usually, my reaction is,
what the hell was I thinking?
And maybe six months later, I
have some kind of realistic--
I can see what I was
thinking, and they're halfway
good, halfway bad.
Fundamentally, by the way,
I don't throw images away.
If something is totally
black, I'll delete it.
But otherwise, I long
ago made the decision
that considering how
cheap storage space is,
it's really more expensive
to take the time to go
through them well and avoid--
that I'm going to
throw away some things
I later want if I'm
not very careful.
And to take the time to be very
careful about doing that is
a mistaken priority, basically.
You know, there's no
magic word with this.
The other thing I'd
say is that the process
of digital photography
itself sometimes
requires overshooting
because, A, I
do a lot of bracketed
sequences, and, B,
since part of what
I do sometimes
is put disparate things
together from a similar scene,
I want to try to cover all
bases when I'm in a thing.
I'm going, for example, next
month to the world's largest
cave in Vietnam, which
is quite an expedition
to get to and so on.
And the real cost
is getting me there.
It's not what I
do once I'm there.
And if I'm there
and taking an image,
I want to make sure
I get all pieces
that I might possibly need.
So that leads to a
bit of overshooting.
And obviously, I don't end up
using all those pieces a lot
of the time.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: How has that changed
since you made the switch
from film to digital?
Were you overshooting
on film as well?
HAROLD DAVIS: No, it
was too expensive.
What I do find in
my workshops is
that some of the
best students are
people who had a real
background in film photography
because there was a discipline
to that that, in some ways,
you just don't have with digital
because it's so easy to just
keep pressing that button.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I just started taking photos.
Do you have any simple
tricks to take a photo
when you are facing
a light source
and taking a photo of a person?
It just shows up as
black when I take it.
HAROLD DAVIS: Yeah, so
it's going to do that.
Again, what I said
is watch the light.
So that's what's called
a backlit situation.
So you've got two ways you can
deal with that, if you want.
If you are a professional
photographer and someone said,
I'm handing you your
day rate, you've
got to make a decent
portrait of this person
with a backlight,
technique number one
and probably the best bet is to
use what's called a fill flash
strobe in the front.
So you take a flash unit.
You attach it via either
a wireless or wire line
to the camera.
You hold it up here.
You have some kind
of diffuser in it.
You use the controller
in your camera
to set it to fill mode so it
isn't going to totally blanch
out everything.
And you use that to light
the face of the subject.
So that's probably
the number-one way
professionals would do that.
The other possibility,
if you have
the time and a very
willing subject,
you put the camera on a tripod,
and you do a bracketed exposure
sequence.
So you get one for the
front and one for the back,
and then you combine the two.
AUDIENCE: How about to
doing this on a phone?
HAROLD DAVIS: You can do either
of those two things on a phone
as well, but it takes a
little more gimcrackery.
There are a couple of programs,
Leonardo, Image Blender,
are two of them that let you
combine different exposures.
You actually can control the
exposure on an iPhone to some
degree by where you tap
with the native camera app,
but also by using either Red
Dot+ Camera or Camera+ app.
And you can actually
control the exposures,
and then you can
combine and blend them.
AUDIENCE: I see.
Thank you.
SHILPA: On average,
piggybacking off
that question, how long do
you take from actually taking
the photo or even
setting up for the image
and to the whole post-processing
part of the workflow to when
you're like, this is
done, this is complete.
How long does that typically
take you, on average?
HAROLD DAVIS: Yeah,
it's hard to give you
a single number on that.
It really depends on the image.
The image I posted
on the top of my blog
from the Brooklyn
Bridge last night,
if anyone wants to look at
that, was about an hour.
Some images take months.
Yeah.
SHILPA: OK.
That's fair.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Any advice you would give about
getting into model photography
or people photography?
As a software developer,
it's pretty easy
to go and shoot landscapes.
But when photos involve
people you have to direct,
that is a bit harder.
HAROLD DAVIS: Well,
I'm not sure I
agree with the premise
of your question,
but it's a good question.
I would say, actually, starting
with models is a good idea
because there are
some basics about how
you want to compose
and light people
that you can learn with a model.
And a professional model is
actually a very good person
to help guide you
to how to do it,
and to learn what
works and doesn't work,
and also how to use
studio lighting,
if that's how you're doing it.
And actually,
professional models
are really not that expensive
for photographers to hire.
So it's-- a typical going
rate's about $100 an hour.
You said model and
then portraits,
and the two are pretty
different things, really.
But I would consider
starting with a model.
And I would consider finding a
meetup, or a photography club,
or something like that
that organizes model
shoots for the first
couple of times
so that you don't have to
worry about getting the studio
lights together, and
the studio space,
and hiring the model,
and everything like that,
so you can see how it's done.
It's not very hard to take
basic pictures of people
in a studio that are well-lit.
What becomes hard is to take
something that says something
about the person and so on.
And that comes back to become
a more interesting person
because, to do that,
you need to have
a dialogue with the person.
They need to feel
at ease with you.
You need to feel out a way to
get them to reveal themselves.
There's a very famous portrait
that the photographer Arnold
Newman took of the industrialist
Krupp, who, in Germany,
he employed slave labor during
the period up to the Second
World War and so on.
And he managed to
get Krupp to pose
with lighting in
front of his factory
so that Krupp looks
like he basically
is a walking skull on top.
It's a very evil portrait.
He conveys the man completely.
And the man was very careful
to try to not put himself
in that situation.
And the rumor is that
some of Krupp's people
tried to steal the negative
back from him after they
realized what he'd done.
So the right kind of portrait
can be very revealing,
but you need to understand
the person that you're
trying to make the portrait of.
It's not really something
that's easy to do in a flip way.
The technical side
of it, though,
as I said at the
beginning of this talk,
is really not that hard.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Harold, thanks
for coming to talk to us.
This is the brightest light
I've ever seen in my life,
by the way, Shilpa.
Just a heads up.
HAROLD DAVIS: Tell me about it.
AUDIENCE: So I was curious.
For amateurs or
semi-professional photographers
that are looking to
increase their income
in a saturated
photography market,
do you have any suggestions
for the most efficient manner
of making that happen?
Besides the whole art and
the hobby form of that,
there's a lot of
us that might be
interested in paying off some of
the gear that's been purchased.
HAROLD DAVIS: That's a
very interesting question,
and there are several different
ways I can address it, really.
One thing I would
say as an overview
is that the various things
that have decimated part
of the business of photography.
For example, the lower end
wedding photography business
is dead, and that's because
cousin Joe takes the photos.
And as someone
notoriously said, we're
all photographers these days.
But the very same forces
that have done that
have also led to increased
opportunities too.
And that's a very
interesting thing.
I, for example, recently
licensed a whole lot
of photos for an annual
report to a hedge fund
based in Singapore.
They found me on
my Flickr stream.
This is something that
you could have only done
through an agent, if
at all, 20 years ago.
So Google Search
giveth and Google
Search taketh in this
particular realm.
And the people who know how
to use social media correctly
probably are the winners here.
What I tell students
who ask that question--
and they're all full
of marketing schemes--
the best thing you
can do is to really do
beautiful photos or great
photos and get them out there.
The cream does tend
to rise to the top.
And actually, if you put
things on a website, or a blog,
or a photo-sharing site, if
it's a really good image,
people will notice it.
So that's really
my recommendation.
It doesn't sound terribly
commercial, but it works.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SHILPA: When you're
talking about posting,
is there a platform that's
worked best for you?
Is it Flickr?
Is it Tumblr?
Is it Instagram?
Where do you find
the most success
in drawing in followers?
HAROLD DAVIS: That's
a great question.
First of all, every
professional photographer
I know who makes a
living at it has found
their own unique
path, so whatever I do
is likely to not work
for somebody else.
My most important
venue is my own blog.
I've been blogging since 2005,
10 to 30 stories a month.
And I do it for myself.
It's my day book.
The way Edward Weston, the
photographer, had a day book.
He kept notes about
his photography.
For a niche blog, I have a
reasonably high readership,
and I get solicited to
place advertisements on it.
I long ago decided the only
thing I'm advertising is me.
So it's a commercial-free site.
And that really works
quite well for me.
It's a WordPress blog, but
one that I maintain myself
with a bulletproof
WordPress host.
So that works well.
Flickr's worked
very well for me.
I'm not a big
Facebook person, but I
have to maintain a presence
there and on Twitter.
So however they want to
find me, they can find me.
SHILPA: It was funny.
So I was reading
Harold's blog, and it
says that you are not a fan
of the generation of selfies,
but you still embrace social
media and all the platforms,
which is great.
Just because the world
is taking selfies,
and there is a lot of
things that are promoting
and devices that are
selling because of them.
What are your
opinions about that?
HAROLD DAVIS: Well, thank you.
I have a little
personal frustration
in that I'll go
someplace to photograph,
and I'll get out
my tripod, and I'll
get out the 36-megapixel
camera, and I'll
put a nice piece of
ZEISS glass on it.
And then somebody is going to
run up with their selfie stick
and camera and get
right in front of me
and whatever I'm photographing.
It's like, oh, please.
But I don't know.
I don't get the urge, really.
It's like, eh.
Maybe I'm not in love with my
own face enough or something.
So I do a lot of traveling.
I'm going to be in
five or six countries
in the next two months,
and a lot of them
are wonderful places,
and it's fun to go there.
But I think that a lot
of these selfie things
are about proving that one
has had these experiences
rather than actually
having the experiences.
And that's, I think, what it
really comes down to for me.
SHILPA: That's an
interesting perspective.
So my last question
to leave us with today
is, where is one
place that you're
looking to photograph next?
And what story have
you still not told
that you are wanting to
still share with the world?
HAROLD DAVIS: Thank you.
Well, I'm going to this
wonderful, huge cave in Vietnam
next month.
It's big enough to
put a skyscraper in.
It's got its own rivers,
ecosystems, plants,
and cathedral-like entrances.
It's about a day's walk in the
jungle to get to the entrance.
So that's high on my list.
I'm also going to the mountains
in the north of Vietnam
on the Chinese
border, where there
are tribal languages spoken.
SHILPA: Oh, wow,
that sounds amazing.
HAROLD DAVIS: But there are many
parts of this beautiful world,
and I've seen only a few so far.
So there is much
that I want to do.
The broader question, just
in as humble a way as I can,
I just want to work to be the
best person, artist, and part
of our society that I can be.
That's really--
SHILPA: Thank you so much.
Well said.
Very beautifully said.
We have one more last
question from the audience.
So, Joe.
JOE: One more.
So just a question
on your last comment.
You take so many
majestic photos and go
to so many beautiful
places, which is great.
But I think, maybe for a
beginning photographer,
it could also be inhibiting
because, well, I'm never
going to go to
that crazy cavern,
so should I even bother
taking a picture?
What are some examples
of some mundane things
that you've seen that you've
made into great photos?
HAROLD DAVIS: Well, I
mentioned a couple of them
just a short while ago.
For example, the Brooklyn
Bridge last night and the fire
hydrant I photographed
on the way up here.
And even that tool bench
with the Russian thing
that I started my slide off
with, or a nautilus shell.
These are things that are
accessible to everyone.
I think New York is a
great place to photograph,
and there are some wonderful
images to be made here.
In fact, looking at New
York and coming back--
I grew up here
and have been away
for maybe a quarter of a
century living other places.
Coming back here,
it's amazing what
transformation is happening
all around and everywhere.
What an incredible
thing to photograph.
I would just also make
one other comment,
and that is that I'm a believer
in a concept called resistance.
That something tries to stop
us from being our creative,
best selves.
And what you said is one form--
it's one I feel too--
one form of resistance.
One form of resistance for me
is I have to get somewhere.
I have to take one of my kids
to a doctor, whatever it is.
And so I don't stop
to make the photo.
But what you're
saying, it's already
been done, why should I bother,
is another form of resistance.
And generally, whenever you feel
that, the best thing you can do
is say, screw you, resistance.
I'm going to do it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SHILPA: Well, on
that note, thank
you so much for being with
us here at Talks at Google.
It's a pleasure having you.
The books are in the
back of the room.
Everyone, grab a copy of "The
Photographer's Black and White
Handbook."
And if you can stick around,
hopefully, you can sign a few.
HAROLD DAVIS: Be
my great pleasure.
SHILPA: Thank you so much.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]